the Smithsonian's National Museum of
african-american history and culture
opens its doors to the public for the
first time next Saturday September 24th
American History TV will be live from
the National Mall starting at 8:00 a.m.
Eastern with sights and sounds leading
up to the 10:00 a.m. opening ceremony
and will be live with the dedication
which includes remarks by President
Obama and founding museum director
Lonnie bunch this is American history TV
only on c-span three
next on history bookshelf journalist
Cokie Roberts talks about her book
capital Dame's the Civil War and the
women of Washington 1848 to 1868
she reads letters from influential women
who worked and lived in Washington DC in
the midst of the Civil War including
Adele Cutts Douglas the wife of Senator
Stephen Douglas and Verina Davis the
wife of Confederate President Jefferson
Davis this was recorded at politics and
prose bookstore in Washington DC in 2015
it's about 50 minutes
well thank you listen this is a neighbor
of mine as well we live very close to
each other I live in the house that I
grew up in she's newer to the
neighborhood then she probably moves
there before she was born but but the
but what a fabulous contribution listen
Brad have made to this community really
and in addition to taking on this this
now legendary store a legend in
Washington doing the National Book Fair
was really a challenge and one that was
well met it didn't you guys go my
grandsons are here you have to pay
attention you have to sit up and pay
attention but it really they did a
fabulous job
my college roommate is here you see it's
all the old and another college class
made well you know it's the old gang
it's him and and barber Stevens my
roommate when I was in college helped me
type my papers late at night and she
couldn't help me finish this book and it
was really upsetting to me because I was
very late in getting it in but but it
was great fun to do I I appreciate your
words list about the women I started on
this quest about women and history
really as a result of growing up with my
mother and many of you knew her Lindy
Boggs she I watched when I was growing
up here and in post-world War to
Washington the the women my mother and
her cohorts running everything you know
they they ran the political conventions
they ran the the voter registration
drives they ran their husband's
campaigns they ran their offices and
along with the african-american women in
Washington they ran all the social
service agencies and and in fact when my
father was killed in the plane crash and
my mother then ran for Congress she
called
ladybird Johnson who was one of her
closest closest friends and one of this
group of remarkable women and she told
her witch that she was going to run for
Congress and didn't want mrs. Johnson to
read it in the paper and Lady Bird said
well that's nice Lindy but how are you
gonna do it without a wife and and that
was you know a very good question and
when the mama had a hard time with
because she ended up playing both roles
of course and making it twice as hard
but it was it wasn't an experience in a
way of growing up that really did give
me a deep appreciation for the women in
in politics now and for women in history
and I got very particularly interested
in the women of the Revolutionary period
because I have to deal with the founding
fathers all the time I mean yes I know
them all by first names I'm not crazy
about them I I admire them but you know
once you start reading their wives
letters you like them less but the but
the but that's an era that you know if
you cover Congress and politics as long
as I have you you deal with constantly
and and they're invoked constantly right
the founders said this the people who
say that by the way mainly in the United
States Senate have it wrong about 99.9
percent of the time and so you know I
was always going back to see what they
actually did say about religion in the
public square or the right to bear arms
or whatever it was now why you have to
be an American a child of American
citizens to be President it turns out
you don't have to be born in America
Canada will do but which seems to put
the whole keenya thing to rest but it's
interesting but so I you know I had
gotten to know the men and I started to
be very curious about what the women
were up to and I really didn't know
anything and so I went back to find out
and the reason I didn't know anything is
because it really hadn't been written
with the exception of a couple of good
biographies of Abigail Adams there
really wasn't anything now since then
there's a few quite good books have come
out but it wasn't true at the time you
can't hear okay thank you
is that any better okay thank you thank
you so I I so that's how I wrote
founding mothers and then the sequel
ladies of Liberty taking us through John
Quincy Adams inauguration which is
literally the next generation so I there
there I was and I had done it and I was
happy with it but then the publisher
wanted a Civil War book I never intended
to write a Civil War book first of all
all of my relatives were on the losing
side and then they did all fight and
lost and and it's an awful war you know
it's it's 600,000 dead Americans
fighting each other but they really did
want a book so I started really puzzling
around about what it would be what I did
know is that whatever it would be I
would love the letters because women's
letters are fabulous they are so much
better than men's letters it's just no
they really are because the men knew
that they were doing something
extraordinary even the ones who weren't
and they and they and they so they wrote
with that in mind so their their letters
are studied and edited and often pompous
and focused and all of that the women
just wrote letters so they would they
were full of politics that women were
deeply political but they also would
talk about the economic situation who
was having and all too often losing
babies and fashion all of it all of life
is in the letters and they are funny and
they're frank and feisty and honest in
ways that you don't find with the men
and my person and and and most of them
have never been published before so I'm
always on the
Qwest you know to see I don't know what
I'm getting and so I'm reading the long
and seeing what it is you know what I'm
what I can learn and my personal
favourite actually remains one from the
from ladies of Liberty it was a letter
written by Louisa Catherine Adams who
was the wife of John Quincy Adams and
she it was here in Washington in 1820
and he was Secretary of State and she
had written she wrote these chatty
letters home to Oh John Adams Abigail he
died and he was lonely and so she had
written him at one point saying it was
her vocation to get her husband elected
president and so it's the Year 1820 it's
the year of the Missouri Compromise
Congress stayed in session much longer
than usual because of hammering out the
compromise and finally they adjourned
she goes to a meeting of the Orphan
Asylum trustees at Dolly Madison had
with the local women here founded the
Orphan Asylum after the British Invasion
in 1814 so she goes to me the trustees
and one of the trustees says to her that
they're gonna need a new building and
she said why what are you talking about
and the woman said the session had been
very long the fathers of the nation had
left 40 cases to be provided for by the
public and our institution was the most
likely to be called upon to maintain
this elicit progeny 40 pregnant women
left behind and there were only about
200 members of Congress now some of them
could have been recidivist I don't know
but anyway so she says to John Adams I
recommended a petition to Congress next
session for that great and moral body to
establish a foundling institution and
should certainly move that the two
additional dollars a day which they have
given themselves as an increase in pay
may be appropriated as a fund toward the
support of the institution now
it doesn't get any better than that and
I mean when I discovered this I just
couldn't believe it and so I I knew I
knew whatever this book was going to be
that I would come upon wonderful letters
like that and it turns out in fact her
daughter-in-law Abigail Brooks Adams who
was married to Charles Francis Adams who
was here briefly in Congress and then
became the union's ambassador to the
court of st. James and was very
instrumental in keeping the British from
recognizing the Confederacy but while
they were here in Washington it was the
infamous 36 Congress which was the
Secession Congress and she's writing
home these unbelievably Frank letters to
her son Henry Adams and she says of
President Buchanan that he is a heavy
old toad and the Senate behaved like
children and silly ones at that now I
mean we can get behind this and but
again my favorite I would advise any
young woman who wishes to have an easy
quiet life not to marry and Adams so so
you know I knew whatever I did that the
that the letters would be great but I
still didn't know what the book was and
so I started thinking about again my own
growing up here after World War two and
the effects of the war were very
physically present the the mall was
covered with temporary buildings and
they had initially gone up in World War
one and then more had been added in
World War two I remember asking my
parents what temporary meant because
they didn't seem to be going anywhere
and and they were there for a long time
until those big buildings were built on
Independence Avenue so you saw
physically how the war had increased the
government and made the city a bigger
more important city and we knew the
stories or at least learned the stories
of Rosie the Riveter and the government
girls who came into town and large
numbers to staff the bureaucracy
and and I knew because again I covered
it and written about it that I hadn't
covered the forties conventions but I
had written about them that it after the
war the women's movement really did come
into focus and the Equal Rights
Amendment was introduced in the first
Republican convention after the war and
then the Democrats the next time around
so it had it had spurred on the women's
movement and there was this myth that
women had all gone home after the war
but just simply wasn't true
women were occupying all kinds of
positions that they had never occupied
before 60,000 women took advantage of
the GI Bill and and brought themselves
to where we are now where the majority
of college graduates are female so I
started thinking I wonder if the Civil
War had a similar impact on the role of
women the place of women and the role of
Washington and as I started to do the
research I found out absolutely and
dramatically so and so that's the book
and it turned out to be fascinating to
to learn about and to and to write rosie
the riveter women came in to work in the
Arsenal's and all over the north but in
Washington they were a couple of dozen
very young women were killed in a
horrible Arsenal explosion and the
newspaper stories about it are just
terrific because they the take they
uncover the women the next day and their
bodies are unrecognizable but the
reporter says but they were trapped in
their hoop skirts so they they were in
Washington in the middle of July doing
this incredibly dangerous work of
stuffing the ammunition for action
creating the ammunition and and there
they were dressed as the proper ladies
for the 19th century there was a huge
funeral led by the president in the
Secretary of War and there is a very
beautiful monument to them at the
Congressional Cemetery but the president
giving giving due to the huge
contribution they had made to
the war effort government girls same
thing women started arriving in
Washington just as they did in World War
two mainly initially just to make a
living because the men are gone they
needed a job but then it was fortuitous
with women just as they started showing
up Congress authorized the printing of
paper money to pay for the war and the
money as I mean many of you've probably
been to see it be made it's so much fun
you know it comes off the machines and
these great huge sheets and of course
now the bills are cut up by machines but
that required somebody sitting with a
pair of scissors you know cutting out
each bill and the treasurer of the
United States General Skinner said women
are just better with scissors than men
ARB and and he also allowed us how he
could pay the women less is something
that I've had several bosses say along
the way in a career but so you had by
the end of the war one of the women
journalists saying and she documents it
that there were women in every
department of government and that had
just not been true before and they
stayed of course and of course a woman
journalist is another thing there were
women who came to Washington to cover
the politics in the war some had been
here before one Jane Swiss helm who was
an abolitionist and a suffragist and and
a bomb thrower basically but she was the
first woman who had been allowed to
report out of the Capitol press gallery
but before the war but she was soon
kicked out of the Capitol press gallery
because she wrote vicious truths we know
she actually wrote the Daniel Webster
was a drunk and and the men were
horrified and again I was I found it so
recognizable because the same thing had
happened when we women journalists
started covering political campaigns and
got on the bus and you know the boys on
the bus had taken a vow of omertà and
and we hadn't and you know we actually
wrote what went on on the campaign trail
and I remember our
number once coming back after some trip
and I was on the Brinkley show and of
course I was the only woman and and I
said something along the lines of well
you know we do report everything with
the candidates up to you know it's
relevant and I said and of course we
tell stories from the trail you know and
a lot of our best friends are the other
correspondents wives and this look of
total terror came up with the cases and
the timekeeper for the show said there
was 45 solid minutes of silence this
piece of information and then there
women you do know about but you probably
don't know quite how remarkable they are
women like Dorothea Dix and Clara Barton
before the war Dorothea Dix had come to
Washington to lobby for a bill to for
the federal government she wanted the
government to put aside 12 million acres
for the mentally ill and
poverty-stricken and she'd get it put
and I'm the Senate she was already so
influential because of her word for the
mentally ill that the Senate set aside
an office in the Capitol for her from
which to lobby and she'd get it through
one house one session another house
another session finally she gets to both
houses of Congress and President Pierce
vetoes it so she left but before she
left she got Congress to establish st.
Elizabeth's which was called the
government hospital for the insane
then she comes back during the war and
she goes to the Surgeon General and says
that she will be the superintendent of
female nurses but there were no female
nurses nursing wasn't open to women that
was not an open field and and the
Surgeon General was terrified of her and
basically said yes ma'am
you you go do that and and then after
the and and by the way not only was
Nursing not open there was the field of
medicine was barely touched because
women had not been allowed into medical
schools and other so they were they were
basically three or four women doctors by
the time of the war one of them Mary
Walker was a surgeon she
came here to Washington to to get a job
with the Union Army but she ended up
having to volunteer she dressed like a
man so they arrested her all the time
you know just on general principles and
she is still Mary Walker is still the
only woman to have won the medal of
honor and she was surgeon in the Union
Army and and then Clara Barton is one of
those stories where she was from a New
England family a suffragist abolitionist
mother she always chafed against the
fact that she didn't make as much as men
and she and she then came to Washington
to get a job with the government to try
to make more money and she did actually
for a while she was a patent office make
as much as men then the war happens
Massachusetts troops show up in the
Capitol in fact in the Capitol they were
bivouacked in the Senate chamber and and
she started bringing them supplies and
nursing them and reading them newspapers
and all of that so they started writing
home and saying this this woman here who
can do all this so people started from
all over the country started sending
their supplies she went to the
quartermaster general and said I've got
three warehouses full of supplies so he
sent her where she wanted to go which
was to the front and she was incredibly
brave and intrepid through all the wars
around here particularly Antietam which
remains of course the single worst day
in American history in terms of
casualties and then after the war one of
the last acts that Lincoln performed was
to allow her to set up a missing persons
Bureau and so she found missing soldiers
but she also identified the graves of
tens of thousands of soldiers so that
they were given the respect of a marked
grave and not left unknown then she goes
to Europe and discovers something called
the Red Cross and comes back here and
establishes the American Red Cross now
this is one of the
anything's that drives me crazy in
history books I mean Lizza says they
infuriate her this history this this
kind of statement just sends me around
the bend you know and then she
established the American Red Cross
really you know was it hard then did
anything go before that you know is it
was their story there and of course
there was and she she was able to get a
Red Cross going in the United States but
it didn't have the clout of being
aligned with the International Red Cross
where it could really do some work
because Senate first had to ratify the
Geneva Conventions in order for them to
be part of the International Red Cross
for two decades she lobbied the Senate
and finally got the Senate to ratify the
geneva treaty she's then the
representative to Geneva puts in what's
called the American Amendment which
allowed still called that which allows
the Red Cross to go into disaster zones
as well as war zones so right now in
Nepal after the earthquake with the Red
Cross there it's the result of the
lobbying the Clara Barton did 130 years
ago so yeah it's really a wonderful
story and so all of these things were
showing me how similar it was to World
War two but and also just fascinating me
and of course what I was the people I
was most interested in because of what I
do for a living and also how I grew up
it was the political women and they were
just wonderful to read about before the
war the Society was really ruled by
Southern women they were a lot more fun
if the truth be told and and they and
they referred to themselves as Belles
and there was a certain amount of vying
among them but there was also a great
deal of friendship and their letters are
full of politics but their letters are
also again very very frank and at one
point
and adele Cutts who they all loved she
was dolley Madison's great niece and she
was brilliant and she was beautiful and
she was kind and all the women write
about her they all liked her and she was
going to they discovered she was going
to marry Stephen Douglas none of them
could stand Stephen Douglas and and he
was considerably older and had a couple
of kids and so verinha Davis Jefferson
Davis's wife writes home to her mother
and says the dirty speculator and party
trickster broken and health by drink
with his first wife's money buys an
elegant well-bred woman because she is
poor and her father is proud and marina
says fortunately Washington is getting a
new water system
so sparing his wife's olfactories
Douglas may wash a little oftener if he
don't his acquaintance will build larger
rooms with more perfect ventilation now
you know the men don't write the Stephen
Douglas tank and so he's still defeated
Lincoln a couple of years later for the
Senate but but she she turns out to be
one of the most delightful women and her
letters are quite wonderful
she stayed friendly throughout the war
even after the her state secede
Mississippi was where he was from
Mississippi seceded and he became
president of Confederacy and she
actually knew from the beginning she
wrote to her mother that there was no
way that this was gonna work you know
she just did an analysis says well you
know we don't have enough manufacturing
we don't have enough railroads we can't
win this war but I'll do my duty she
said and so while she went to Richmond
but she stayed friendly with her friends
in the North particularly Elizabeth
Blair Lee who we all know from Blair
House and and Montgomery Blair and all
of that and and Montgomery Blair was her
brother he was in Lincoln's cabinet of
course her father Francis Preston Blair
was a Lincoln confidant and adviser her
other brother Frank Blair was a
congressman her husband phillips lee was
robert e lee's cousin but he was an
officer in the Union Navy and because he
was in the Navy she wrote to him almost
every day so there are thousands of
letters and her wartime letters are
actually published but they're plenty
more on both sides of the war happily at
Princeton but so her letters really give
you a sense of what's happening here all
through the war and how much danger
Washington was in which was something I
really had not focused on particularly
at the beginning of the war when there
was every expectation that the
southerners would just come in and and
burned the place down and until the
forts were built around it you know Fort
Reno and Fort Stevens and all the ones
would go by it was really unsafe and I
found a diary and unpublished diary from
1861 that first year of the woman who
was the farmer at Rosedale and so she
really talks about how scary it is and
and she's a Confederate sympathizer as
where most of the people in town and and
so she's telling her children just keep
quiet for God's sake you know because
you know loose lips sink ships but in
her case she was afraid they'd say
something intemperate and the Union Army
would get them and she was completely
cut off from her children in Virginia so
you really get a sense of that of
somebody you can recognize because she's
right here at Rosedale Elizabeth Lizzie
Lee was one of the few people who tried
to befriend Mary Lincoln not easy
she was really difficult I think today
should probably be diagnosed as bipolar
she was certainly mercurial she let her
views be known to everybody about you
know how she who she thought was awful
and the cabinet which was pretty much
the cabinet and and she kept making
enemies and the press was all over her
they followed her everywhere wrote about
everything she did all of her shopping
all
that she was accused of leaking the
State of the Union message to the New
York Herald either in exchange for good
publicity or money depending on whose
story you're reading the Congress
launched an investigation into the first
lady's communications so you see things
don't change and and the president
actually went to the hill and said
because it was a Republican Congress he
could do this he said you know please
don't subpoena my wife it will be very
embarrassing to me but they did a full
investigation and it was not you know
pretty the women of Washington really
didn't like her and it was somewhat
reciprocated so her best friend became
Elizabeth Keckley and Elizabeth Keckley
was a former slave who had bought her
freedom and come here she was a very
very talented dressmaker couturier she
ran a very profitable business all of
these prominent women went to her and
had her make their best dresses so Mary
Lincoln wanted the best and hired her
and they became very good friends and
mrs. Keckley was in the conversations
with the President and First Lady the
first lady also told her many things
herself she helped take care of Mary
Lincoln after Willie died and then after
the president was shot mrs. Lincoln was
in the White House for two months and
out of her mind and mrs. Keckley took
care of her then and then took her back
to Illinois and got her set up and then
she wrote a tell-all book I mean it's
really remarkable how things don't
change and and of course that severed
the relationship and it also ruined your
business because other people were
worried that it she might do the same
but it allowed her to then pursue her
real passion which was social service
because she had understood as a formerly
enslaved person what the situation was
with the the first it was escaped slave
coming in or those who had gone to the
Union Army called contrivance and then
after emancipation Freedman and she
understood that there were many
particularly the elderly who had no
wherewithal to get a job or housing or
anything so she established a relief
organization and because she had such
prominent friends was able to raise a
good deal of money and awareness of the
issue and so she was able to then after
after her business fell apart to really
throw her energies into the Freedman
relief as many other women actually came
to town to work in as well and that was
that was what really struck me and in
the end was how after the war as a
result of the experiences during the war
these women did move out front and take
on their own causes and their own issues
and they had been very involved and very
influential behind the scenes but now
they were marching on to the public
stage themselves and so marina Davis for
instance after the war after she got her
husband out of jail which was you know
because he had been put in jail as part
of the conspiracy to assassinate Lincoln
which was a crock but you know there he
was she she prevailed upon Andrew
Johnson to get him out of jail which is
another thing you cannot get over in
this book how these women are in and out
of the White House all of the time just
giving the president's unsure did grief
I mean it is fabulous I am so jealous it
is you know they they just they have
complete access and and so after she
gets her husband out of jail it's they
have a tough time and he finally dies
and she decides to move to New York
where she had a job with the New York
world as a journalist and it was a huge
scandal right the first lady of the
Confederacy moving to New York City and
people offered her a house in Richmond
and all that and she said she didn't
want that she wanted to move to New York
and she had never been fully accepted by
the south their grandfather was the
New Jersey and she was olive complected
she was never quite fair enough for the
perfect southern belle so as she's
moving to New York she writes to her
daughter and says I am free Brown and 64
I can do whatever I want to do but then
she got there and she was a journalist
and ran something of a salon but she
befriended Julia grant and it was page 1
news in all of the newspapers when she
and mrs. Grant met and and then she went
to the dedication of the grant memorial
very publicly because what she was
engaged in was a very public series of
acts of reconciliation of bringing the
sections of the country back together
and she was doing this she wasn't trying
to influence a man to do it she was
doing it herself with her own voice very
publicly and similarly some of the other
Belle's the same thing there's a
wonderful delightful woman named
Virginia clay who wrote a book about
herself called a bell of the 50s and and
after the war she became an ardent
suffragists and was on platforms with
horace greeley and william mrs. William
Lloyd Garrison people her husband who
was a senator from Alabama had fought
bitterly before the war and now she was
she was with them again in this public
act of reconciliation but also with a
cause that she felt that she could use
her voice to promote and all the
newspapers say that her voice was
terribly important and one of the great
things now is that you can read all the
newspapers they're online and so you can
waste days you know because there's so
much fun to read and and that interested
me too because when I was growing up it
was always said that a proper lady
was only in the paper when she was born
married and died and and these women
were in the papers all the time they
were written about constantly and so she
was very much out in front again after
the
or another southerner sarah prior who
went to new york became a noted writer
and created several important relief
organizations worked with Elizabeth
Blair Lee who had stayed here and stayed
true to the Union to help establish the
Daughters of the American Revolution
again in an act of reconciliation going
back to an earlier time when the country
was together and had a common cause and
so they really did stand there on their
own two feet in front of the public and
and make their cases with their own
voices having been greatly empowered by
the war and Clara Barton in looking back
on it at a memorial day address a couple
of decades later said woman was at least
fifty years in advance of the normal
position which continued peace would
have assigned her so it is quite a story
I I loved getting to know these women I
know you will too thank you for letting
me share them with you and I'd be
delighted to take your questions
questions there's a microphone right
there why does it seem like in history
the women always seem to be conveniently
deleted from history why are the women
conveniently deleted from the histories
because the men don't care
but as Lissa said earlier it's it's
infuriating it's also inaccurate
you can't tell history leaving out half
of the human race and have an accurate
history so I you know I just feel it
yeah thank you so but also it's so much
more fun to have them they're there
they're just more interesting I I
thought you and mr. Beschloss were
terrific at the National Archives a
couple weeks of wonderful program thank
you you mentioned there kind of in
passing how many of these people either
went to visitation school or had a role
there can you talk a little bit more
hesitation stayed in operation all
through the war it had always accepted
girls of every faith and all regions and
actually remarkably quite a few stayed
through the war the most of the schools
and hotels and everything were taken
over either to house troops or as
hospitals because Washington became one
great stinking Hospital during the war
because everybody coming in from all the
battles around came into Washington
visitation was untouched because
Winfield Scott who had been of the chief
General before the war his daughter had
become a visitation done and she was
buried there so he protected visitation
and it was never taken over but it
continued to operate all through the war
and a lot of these women went there
let's get some girls asking questions
but you go ahead you found some
wonderful things about Mary Todd Lincoln
did you have an unexpected favorite
source for Mary Todd Lincoln no you know
I didn't really spend that much time
delving into Mary Todd Lincoln because
she she has been written about a good
deal obviously I had to deal with her
she was the first lady so I was I the
parts that I found interesting were what
other people who were contemporaries
wrote about her because again it was
first-person and they they saw it now
they all had views but an Elizabeth
Keckley book is very eye-opening about
the White House and what was going on in
the White House but then also her niece
so toward the end of the war Mary
Lincoln's half-sister came and stayed in
the White House for about a week
her husband was in the Confederate Army
and he had been killed Mary Lincoln's
brothers and half-brother half-brothers
and and brothers-in-law were all in the
Confederate Army and which made her
suspect to the north the way
Verena Davis was suspect to the south
and so this half-sister came and stayed
and that woman's daughter later wrote a
book defending her aunt Mary but also it
was very clear from that book how very
crazy Mary Lincoln was at that point her
said her sister had kept a diary and she
during her week in the White House or 10
days whatever and Mary had come in and
told her that Willie came to her bed at
night and all of that and she did have
seances in the White House
Keckley is the only one that I know of
who mentions that Mary tells that
Stephen Douglas courted her at the same
time as Abraham Lincoln long before they
were in the device no he did that's true
Stephen Douglas did woo and lose Mary
let Mary Todd she was she was looking
for a president and and know she really
was and even though everybody thought
Stephen Douglas was the presidential
material guy she saw something she could
mold and Abraham Lincoln and it was a
love match they absolutely loved each
other but it was just tortured she was
smart and she was politically acute she
was just she she had a difficult time
she knew better I mean she you know she
did take the yes the what the tales that
you've told so far are just so
interesting and I actually have already
bought your book it started it but
haven't gotten far enough to really read
some of this but in any event I just was
thinking about any is there any chance
of a documentary about some of these
fantastic when my documentary producer
would have to decide to do a documentary
that's not me
till somebody else goes to the mic I'm
assuming there are women that you were
interested in writing about that perhaps
you couldn't because the documentation
this was well I doubt cuts is really the
the main one there so I was I I wanted
to stay in Washington because otherwise
you're just too diffused and also I do
Washington well you know and so no I did
because one of the things I've learned
it's quite interested in reading history
is that academic historians often get
the history right and the politics wrong
and you know it really is helpful to
know how to analyze politics in order to
to write these books and so I wanted to
have sort of equal numbers of
northerners and southerners so and and
in reading nineteenth-century books the
same women started being mentioned and
so so then I did go searching for their
papers and Adele cuts I never found any
papers I found the University of Chicago
had letters to her mainly after Stephen
Douglas died and a few others you know
Sarah Pryor who's one of the women I
write about Senator recipe there was a
senator arrested me
she surprised him to send people
Virginia hams and and she sent her a
recipe that said unless you boil it
overnight in Champaign as they do in new
audience this is the recipe but but I
found hardly anything at all written by
her but she's still in there because
everybody else talked about her so much
and and the newspaper when she died the
newspaper was referred to her as a
popular icon so she was a personage no
but for the most of the others I was
able to find papers in a lot of them
unpublished papers
I just would have liked of known what
she had to say I don't hear her voice
you know everybody else likes her and
they say she's really smart and she's
and she's wonderful and she's this and
she's that every so often I mean after
Douglas died and the whole world was
wooing her cuz she was considered a
great beauty she she did tell Frances
Preston Blair that that you know she
didn't want to marry she she didn't want
to settle and so she did eventually
remarry a Union officer and had six
children
no can you hear me yes I just wanted to
ask how did you find all these letters
did you have to write across the country
no you know modern technology is a
wonderful thing from so I found me
mothers came out in 2004 so I guess I
started working on that you know around
2000 around 2001 and then you really did
have to go you know its places but now
you can see you can see where the guys
papers are and then from is you know
mrs. Google does that for you and and
the and then you you get in touch with
those libraries or historic societies
and ask if they have the women's papers
if they're not listed and then they have
become far far more accommodating
because now they know what I'm up to and
so they can then scan papers I mean this
is for a fee which was fair enough
they're working so they can scan papers
and send them to you now what you get at
that point is 18 and 19th century
handwritten letters that are written
horizontally and vertically so reading
them as another matter all-together and
i actually did have to hire somebody to
read them I really couldn't decipher a
lot of them leads me to think this is
something that educators are very
concerned about because without children
being taught script today they're not
going to be able to read the
but well and what letters are there
going to be to read also another problem
but the I mean that's one of the great
things about your printer you know is
there yeah because they have a printer
where we're grandparents come in and
write memoirs for their grandchildren
which is wonderful and oral histories
like StoryCorps on NPR and all that are
also ways of recording this history
because we are going to have a dearth of
written materials and I I mean I guess
if somebody subpoenaed you can get an
Instagram out of the clown I assume but
but it's it's it's a problem I have to
ask one more question because I can't
help myself I'm sorry I apologize in
advance for this but given the 2016
presidential race and the gender
dynamics that we're all aware of I'm
just wondering if there is a woman in
your book who transplanted 100-plus 150
years later whatever it is presidential
majority today yes sure I think that
somebody like Verena Davis who Elizabeth
clearly I mean if they if they were in
the right situation they certainly were
knowledgeable enough and and politically
astute in fact the newspaper said of
Elizabeth clearly when she died very few
women have had so broad a political
experience and so I mean I've had the
obituaries fascinating because I was
surprised they even were obituaries you
know and and the only person I couldn't
find an obituary for it was Elizabeth
Keckley
which tells you about the times but but
the but I think that you know given the
ability to have political help and runs
they could have done it easily
the argument that some of those women in
fact had to deal with so many more
constraints and still got a lot of time
absolutely not to mention that they
would lose children all the time
I mean it's it's heartbreaking to read
how many children they lost you know and
of course during the war everybody was
losing children but but little children
mean both Farina Davis and Mary Lincoln
lost sons who were like two years old at
the time and then Willie Lincoln of
course died in the White House so dove
Arena Davis's ten year old died and
Richmond falling off the top of a
building
Louisa Meigs is in the book her husband
Montgomery Meigs we all know in
Washington
she won one October lost a
three-year-old and a ten year old in
some disease that came through I mean so
just living through the day was
incredibly difficult and still they were
as interested in and involved in
politics and in in policy as they were I
just find that so incredibly admirable I
mean they couldn't vote married women
couldn't own property they were the
property of their husbands and and still
their enormous dedication to the to the
country and to the to making it all come
out right I'm just wondering we have
time for one more question if anybody
has one here I'm gonna hand you this but
actually actually do you mind just going
on remembering this is not attached to
them
hi miss Robert I was just wondering in
hearing about these remarkable women who
accomplished so much in the face of so
much discrimination lack of opportunity
what do you see now
currently as being continuing odds that
women face well there are odds you know
there's still there's still is
discrimination it's still very difficult
in some fields and it's also still true
I think the single biggest problem is
that the workplace needs to be far more
caretaker friendly because you cannot
have the best and the brightest meaning
the majority of college graduates and
the vast majority of graduate school
that graduates not able to be as
productive and as able to do their best
work as possible and still be a
competitive society so I think that that
is a challenge that really needs to be
met but I also do feel and don't take
this you know don't get upset modern
women and men too but modern women are a
bunch of sissies I mean you know
compared to what what these women went
through it's just remarkable I mean when
somebody says to me I can't do it all
I feel like say meet your
great-grandmother you know and talk to
her about it because really they did do
it all and they didn't complain about it
no they complained a little bit but
okay thank you okay I hope you all will
pick it up
cookies happy to sign and I just want to
thank her again for both coming and also
for really as I said earlier helping
enrich our understanding of a very
important aspect of our own history so I
don't know if there's another book in
you but if there is I hope you'll come
back to pop Tomatoes Amanda if you
wouldn't mind just holding up your
chairs when we're done and putting them
to the side that will expedite this
[Applause]
on history bookshelf here from the
country's best-known American history
writers of the past decade every
Saturday at 4 p.m. Eastern and you can
watch any of our programs at any time
when you visit our website c-span org
slash history
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span three
next on American history TV author David
Wetzel talks about his book the
vanishing Messiah the life and
resurrections of Francis slaughter the
author describes the mysteries
surrounding the 19th century faith
healer who reportedly cured thousands of
ailing people on the American frontier
before he disappeared from Denver in
1895 the Kansas City Public Library
hosted this event it's about an hour
into ten minutes
thank you thank you Crosby for those
very kind words and welcome to the
Kansas Lee Public Library on a beautiful
Missouri Valley Sunday
my name is Lee I Paul and I head up the
special collections department which is
headquartered just down the way in the
nearby Missouri value room our program
is made possible today by generous grant
from the National Endowment for the
Humanities and it is my pleasure to
present David Wetzel the author of the
new and intriguing Lee entitled book the
vanishing Messiah the life and
resurrections of Francis Schroder this
is a fascinating tale of religion and
religious belief in the American West
and although these events played out
more than a century ago I think the
story possesses elements that still
resonate today
picture this an anonymous figure
suddenly enters the public arena and
almost immediately and magically
captures the attention of the nation
many of those citizens in retrospect may
have been gullible but they did possess
some unfulfilled needs that this
character filled we all have witnessed
such a phenomenon without naming names
nevertheless in these types of tales how
many of the characters just as suddenly
and literally vanish this happened was
water the disappearing faith healer of
the West David has dogged Lee tracked
down the story and has unraveled much of
the mystery and maybe no other scholar
could have done this David comes from
and knows the region where Schlatter
performed his miracles he recently
retired from the Colorado Historical
Society in Denver after 26 years as a
writer historian editor and director of
the Society's publications programs he
knows the history today he lives just a
few blocks away from this library and is
an active supporter of the special
collections so it is with great pleasure
that we have him here to talk about his
new book
please welcome David Wetzel Thank You
Eli I prefer being kind of informal but
with a figure who is unknown virtually
and with the amount of information I
have to give I'm going to be a little
more formal and I normally would be so
if you'll bear with me it was almost
exactly 120 years ago today that the
world's first that the world first
discovered Francis slaughter he was
found wandering from village to village
in the Rio Grande Valley south of
Albuquerque he wore ragged ill-fitting
clothes he had long flowing hair and a
thick beard and on his swollen feet he
wore an old pair of shoes whose tops had
been cut from the soles you'll see a
picture of that people like Francis
slaughter could be found everywhere
wandering the roads and railroad tracks
of the West in the mid-nineteen 1890s
they were the homeless of that area era
of economic depression but slaughter was
different rumor passed from village to
village that he had raised a child twice
from the dead only to lose it a third
time
then came reports that he had healed a
number of villagers simply by the power
of his touch reporters from the
Albuquerque warning Democrat went out in
search of him along along the way they
found firsthand that these reports were
true Giuliano Cedillo who had been
paralyzed in both arms for 16 years was
out working in the fields hey soos
Velasquez blind for three years could
now see and when reporters finally
caught up with slaughter in the town of
Pajarito they were astounded to discover
how much this man reminded them of the
biblical image of Christ when they
interviewed him they learned that he was
39 years old that he was a lifelong
Catholic and that he was the native of
all sauce France
he had been in the United States for
many years working as a cobbler in 1892
his travels took him to Denver where he
worked as a shoemaker for several months
at that time clean shaven and earnest
I'll give you a clean shaven and
nourished slider had taken an interest
in both healing and in the spiritualist
movement those who believe that
communication with the dead was possible
one day at his cobbler's bench a voice
came to him out of nowhere telling him
to write a friend back east whose arm
was paralyzed
slotter doubted what he heard but the
voice came again then he obeyed again I
wrote the letter and later learned that
his friends / lout paralysis had been
healed that was the beginning of his
mission to go forth and heal through
prayer in July 1893 at the behest of the
divine voice slaughter gave up a
shoemakers business and all his
possessions and set out on a journey
that would take him 3,000 miles around
the West all of it on foot he traveled
east across the Colorado Plains
beginning in Denver with the blue line
across Colorado Plains to Kansas City
stayed there for only a few hours
keeping a line of the on the line of the
railroads and a Kansas City he turned
south into present-day Oklahoma he
followed the direction he followed no
direction of his own he was moving
solely of the voice and direction of the
father along the way slaughter argued
bitterly with the father when it
commanded him to beg for food or shelter
by the way the father the voice the
master in some cases all refer to God of
course in this case or to walk an
additional five miles after an
exhausting day but he always lost these
arguments the cobbler always lost his
arguments for the purpose of the journey
was to chasten his human will so that he
could become an instrument of the Father
in Hot Springs Arkansas the farthest
point east in his journey slaughter was
arrested for vagrancy and thrown in jail
he remained there for five months the
victim of brutality by other prisoners
and effects
rotation by his jailers but it was here
near the end of his incarceration that
he had a vision which foretold a far
greater destiny for him than he had
realized before he would continue in his
preparation to be a healer but the
Father's plan encompassed much much more
with this vision before him slaughter
escaped the hotsprings jail and turned
west in his pilgrimage the second part
of his journey proved even more of an
ordeal in the first he suffered
privation exposure and danger as he
walked across Texas New Mexico in
Arizona to Southern California twice he
was robbed and once threatened with
death yet through all of this he held
fast to his mission and obeyed the
commandments of the Father finally when
he arrived in Quintus now a part of Los
Angeles he had achieved the spiritual
strength to begin healing here for for a
time he remained and performed cures on
the Indians of the San Jacinto Valley
probably his first cure